welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and with doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness now only a few
mere weeks away from driving us all mad
with the craziest cameos in the mcu
multiverse we here at new rockstars are
still asking who done it like who is
actually responsible for breaking the
marvel multiverse huh because if doctor
strange is going to be arrested by a
barbershop quartet of ultron bots to be
brought before professor x and mordo and
the illuminati like some type of common
criminal we have to make sure that the
good doctor who cured like half the
universe gets a fair trial after all and
after examining the cosmic crimes of
both the former sorcerer supreme and the
scarlet witch on the health of the
marvel multiverse i must now ask the
jury to turn their attention to the
third most likely culprit to all of this
multiverse chaos the ruler the conqueror
the jonathan the manger the he who
remains himself because you already know
what time it is my nerd babies because
in the criminal justice system the
people are represented by two separate
yet equally important groups in
speculation nation who investigate the
crime and the bald mind readers of the
illuminati who prosecute the defenders
using their stories
now based on how the loki finale ended
it seems like the maniac known as heath
who remains was plotting some really
interesting things before he died
interestingly illegal things well no
multiversal skill anyway in one of these
secret plots that this 5d chess master
has seemingly begun to domino into
fruition through the lifelong
manipulation of the loki variant sylvie
was his own death which technically is a
huge violation and possibly the biggest
violation of what the mcu multiverse
considered to be the natural law
something that mordo was a big fan of in
doctor strange one because if you think
about it he who remains determined what
the natural law even was for eons after
claiming victory royale at the end of
the inter-dimensional inter-kang bonanza
that was you know the first multiversal
war a feat that could only have been
accomplished after weaponizing the dark
interdimensional being known as elias by
controlling the energies of the sacred
timeline from his citadel at the end of
time he who remains was writing all the
rules for reality necessary for the
universe to have a natural beginning
through the big bang and a natural end
via the natural cooling of all the stars
and energy in the universe however
what's super important about he who
remains a story about how he weaponized
goliath is how he found a life because
telling a confused loki and a sylvie
with murder in her eyes that first
variant encountered a creature created
from all the tears in reality tears in
reality that sound a lot like the kind
that have started to open up a lot in
the mcu as evidenced by both the
multiverse of madness trailers as well
as the recently released indie film
spider-man no way home the one where the
girl from euphoria forgets that she fell
in love with the boy and she just
started dating a week ago in europe
and all these terrorism reality also
likely occurred as a direct result of
both the chaos of the natural branching
of the timelines you know before a tva
was around to prune it all into a neat
and tidy bow as well as the all-out
mayhem that all of these bloodthirsty
conquering kang variants were doing in
the multiverse and hey say what you will
about their actions and motives but do
it quietly but the inquisitors
definitely have a sense of style and you
too can have a great look with the help
of our friends over at epic hero shop
they release all kinds of merch based on
the stuff that we are excited about like
marvel dc and star wars and they
actually just re-released some of their
limited edition shirts based on the
mandalorian and the book of bubba fat
and they also have a really cool line
based on the many looks of moon knight
they have a really dope set of hoodies
with one even having a konshu head logo
and the phrase embrace the chaos and the
other having a cool design inspired by
the mr night look which is a pretty dope
look i can't wait to see that in action
so grab one of each so you will always
have one to reflect on which side of the
force that you're feeling that day and
they have all types of clever and fun
merch inspired by spider-man no way home
loki peacemaker and all the other
properties that we are obsessed with and
sign up for their newsletter at the
bottom of their website to get notified
about merch drops and check out all of
their incredible products at the epic
hero shop.com be your own hero since we
already have an idea that multiverse of
madness will directly deal with the
consequences of holes in reality opening
up from both the trailers that we've
gotten so far as well as the impossibly
hard to miss presence of gargantos the
giant squid from another dimension who
much like goliath did for kang and that
tentacle creature did after red skull
and the nerdy jerks at hydrosoft opened
a terror reality in the first episode of
what if likely emerged from one of these
holes in reality that have opened up
because he who remains manipulated
sylvie into killing him specifically
specifically after he allows the sacred
timeline to pass what he calls the
threshold this is super important here
because this is likely the exact cosmic
moment where a kang bored out of his
mind committed the crime because after
countless ages of dictating what the
natural loss of the multiverse were and
having everything he ever wanted after a
long and arduous multiversal war he who
remains likely realized that it wasn't
about the destination but the journey
you take along the way essentially
meaning that this ultimate conqueror
kang variant he who remains missed
conquering and knew that he would be
able to return to doing what he loved
the most after he allowed himself to
lose complete control over the sacred
timeline by crossing the threshold
because it is likely only after this
that he who remains would be able to
reincarnate after his own death because
the last thing his emotionally
traumatized suicide weapon sylvie would
want to do is be in charge of the tva
even if it was to stop the emergence of
an infinite number of the man she hates
the most which is probably why the very
last thing he who remains did before he
passed away was smile and say
and with all the terrors in reality
we've seen come up recently in the mcu
we're likely seeing history repeat
itself here through the re-tearing up of
the ncu multiverse that started after
kang's rare cosmic crime of neglecting
to uphold the natural law with the tva
by freeing himself through sylvie's side
you know cosmic tears like the one that
opened up on the sovereign's homeworld
causing the tentacled abolish to come
through or the one that opened up in tao
lo causing the dark tentacle dweller and
darkness to come through in chongqi
there would be a pattern of portals
opening people and so with marvel
studios subtly dropping in that line
about tears and reality being formed
during the first world war kang while
simultaneously slowly introducing tears
in reality as phase 4 continues to move
along this could very well be the mcu's
way of secretly telling us that despite
his irresponsible use of the time stone
dr steven strange did not in fact break
the multiverse and that the multiverse's
main major pain is indeed major's kang
but that is just the main major cosmic
crime against the multiverse that i can
see committed by the former god of the
natural law himself kang the conqueror
you know after a super brief short cameo
in the loki finale anyway i'm sure
there's lots of crimes for him to commit
very soon especially in ant-man and the
wasps but it doesn't matter what i think
what do you guys think speculation
nation do you guys think it was kang or
do you speculate that it was someone
else other than kang to blame for the
destruction of the multiverse let us
know below my nerd baby so we can
continue doing law and order mcu
together thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media
especially on youtube when you do that
just hit the notification bell and
please be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmirch.com so you can buy our
new batman shirt which is not going to
be around forever this is our new ladies
obsession shirt i love this shirt
because i love the batman so much again
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and spending some time with me
i'll see you guys later i love you guys
so much goodbye
[Music]
you